salut Thomas
du coup j'ai rien préparé j'ai essayé de
vous regarder ce matin c'était un peu
occupé de si de là
bon survitch le vendredi soir twitch et
vous le savez parce que vous connaissez
très bien maintenant
aujourd'hui que le président a été élu
un anniversaire qui a donné lieu à un
concert de casserole devant les mairies
à 20h à la paix de l'association attaque
les ministres papy et Eric
Dupont-Moretti ont eux aussi eu droit à
des casseroles lors d'un entretien avec
les lecteurs du Parisien le chef de
l'État prévient Marine Le Pen arrivera à
l'Elysée si on ne sait pas répondre au
défi du pays
il reconnaît n'avoir pas été assez
présent lors des débats sur la réforme
des retraites certains voient dans ces
mots une attaque contre son propre
gouvernement ça montre bien qu'il pense
que ces ministres n'ont pas été à la
hauteur des cryptes un macroniste le
président qui après une première semaine
de retour sur le terrain saga aussi des
sifflets et des concerts de casseroles
ce n'est pas de la contestation c'est de
l'incivisme déplore-t-il tout en
réaffirmant que sa porte est ouverte au
syndicat y compris à la CGT précise même
Emmanuel Macron il y a ceux qui tiennent
une main sur la rampe finalement c'est
qu'un escalier puis il y a Indiana
Macron qui s'est imaginé perdu en pleine
jungle sur un pont suspendu allez allons
en découdre avec les saints hurleurs et
précise les grands chantiers pour la
suite de son quinquennat pouvoir d'achat
écologie immigration sur ce dernier
point il n'est plus question de
plusieurs textes il plaide pour une
grande loi juste et efficace un autre
visage que j'ai vu de sa personnalité
qui me déplaît énormément quand je
disais que c'est le personnage qu'on
adore détester et là en l'occurrence
c'est vrai je la déteste voilà
pas pour autant se dédire de toutes ces
petites phrases il rejette le procès en
mépris qui lui est fait reconnaît une
vraie faute quand il distinguait les
gens qui réussissent de ceux qui ne sont
rien
ça peut être facile je le crois pas
c'est les journées de grève la
mobilisation contre la réforme des
retraites a été l'obéissime tous les
infidèles ah bah si j'étais serveurs moi
j'étais content d'être serveur mais oui
c'est un boulot comme un autre bébé
pour précisément ne plus être serveur
c'est ma liberté
le cul aussi
tu restes trois heures comme ça avec une
pancarte pour faire ça
elle a fêté les matins après les pirates
télémata elle a fait un truc comme ça on
va se retrouver les gens ils sont
jalouses comment ça se fait que c'est
tout le temps lui-même se retrouve là
juste pour faire oui non elle doit
prendre deux trois quatre mille balles
pour rester le cul 3 heures sur une
chaise c'est se font chier à faire en
sorte de devenir cap superieur chef
d'entreprise avocat médecin architecte
mais ce sont fait chier pour ça ils ont
pas besoin qu'un type anthropologue
éducateur viennent leur prendre 75 % de
leurs revenus pour payer le revenu
universel à des branleurs qui
t'expliquent qu'il y a plus besoin de
boulot parce que il y a l'intelligence
artificielle et c'est un synonyme de
bêtise
je ne sais pas j'ai dit une
source et oui et les mains on pain sont
allongé on tire les 38 000 églises du
pays ont lancé un appel à volontaire de
tous les âges pour apprendre à
carrillonner et faire résonner le
couronnement de Charles III bien au-delà
de la capitale le 6 mai
les gens dans tout le pays vont sonner
les cloches à tout voler et ils vont
faire ça pendant trois heures trois
heures et demie
regardez ces images devant le Théâtre de
Paris où se tient ce soir la cérémonie
des Molières en présence de la ministre
de la Culture Rima Abdul Malak madame la
ministre nous ne sommes pas les chiens
ni des chiennes et nous ne rentrerons
pas la niche alors les frères et à mes
sœurs de lutte que la lutte continue et
vive les casseroles
une dizaine d'heures sont nécessaires
pour apprendre ces gestes précis Anne
porteur en est à son troisième cours
mais cette répétition semble prometteuse
pour cette débutante
pardon je sais que vous avez pas le
temps mais ça va
d'habitude le rôle du ministre c'est de
rester assis à rien dire mais là c'est
pas possible
non juste
faire mine de ne pas voir
un ministère qui a débloqué des aides
massifs pendant la crise pour vous
soutenir tous pour soutenir tous les
secteurs de la culture
vous avez une ministre à la tête de ce
ministère qui a obtenu le budget
historique le plus haut plus 7% par
rapport à l'année dernière inflation
facture d'énergie j'ai débloqué des
aides exceptionnelles vous le savez
certains syndicats sont là pour venir en
aide aux structures les plus fragiles et
puis en Allemagne bonne nouvelle pour
les fonctionnaires qui vont bénéficier
d'une forte hausse de salaire plus 5,5%
à partir de mars 2024 et d'une prime de
3000 euros verset dès le mois prochain
les avantages et obtenus après plusieurs
semaines de grève répétées et de bras de
fer entre les syndicats et le
gouvernement
il y a normalement 5000 euros donc vous
allez aller vers je veux doucement
le 7 février on avait une réunion vous
avez demandé à la reporter on la reporté
au 16 mars vous n'êtes pas venu vous
avez demandé à la reporter elle est
reportée au 27 avril c'est jeudi vous
avez encore demandé à l'annuler il est
encore temps de changer d'avis je suis
là ma porte est ouverte et bonne soirée
à tous
le pays instrument à vent dans les
menteurs sont les vertus
[Applaudissements]